When Dave got his job at the homeless shelter, it was one of the lowest level jobs they had. And he didn't think of advancing up the ladder because he really liked his job.
当戴夫在无家可归者收容所找到工作时，那是他们那儿最低层的工作。他并没有想过要步步高升，因为他真的很喜欢这份工作。
He liked talking with the residents. He helped make meals, did bed checks, rented movies for movie night, got urine samples for drug testing. One guy had scabies and Dave would put lotion on the scabies. He didn't even mind that.
他喜欢和住户们交谈。他帮忙做饭、查房、为电影之夜租电影、收集尿样进行药物测试。有个家伙得了疥疮，戴夫还帮他在疥疮上涂乳液。他甚至一点都不介意这些。
On his weekend shift, he'd pick of all kinds of cake mixes and special ingredients that he would blend together into these crazy cakes for the 200 residents.
周末值班时，他会买各种蛋糕预拌粉和特殊配料，把它们混合在一起，为那里的200名住户制作神奇的蛋糕。
That was my rep. When I would walk in, people would get excited because they knew that an incredible cake was just hours away.
那是我的招牌。我一走进去，大家就会很兴奋，因为他们知道不出几个小时就能吃到超赞的蛋糕了。
So you were good at the job?
所以你很擅长这份工作？
Yeah. I mean, I thought it was fun. One of my favorite things to do was with the urine samples. Because you'd take like a Dixie cup. The supervisor would ask you to go do this.
是啊。我是说，我觉得挺好玩的。我最喜欢做的事情之一就是处理尿样。因为你会拿个迪克西杯子（小纸杯）。主管会叫你去干这事儿。
He would say, would you, you know, go get a urine sample, and so he gave me the cup and then the container to put the urine sample in. I would go do it and then this one time he hadn't come back to his desk yet so I had the urine sample and I got another Dixie cup and ran into the kitchen and filled it with apple juice.
他会说，嘿，你能去取个尿样吗？于是他给了我杯子，还有装尿样的容器。我就去了。有一次他还没回到办公桌前，我手里拿着尿样，又跑进厨房拿了另一个杯子，装满了苹果汁。
So he said, oh, you got the urine sample? I said, yeah, you know, and I acted like, yeah, I did a great job. I got the urine. Here you go. You know, and I'm like, can you get me another vial because I have left over urine. I couldn't fit all the urine into the vial you gave me so I have this cup of urine still.
于是他说，哦，你取到尿样了？我说，是啊，我表现得就像是——我干得非常漂亮。我取到了尿样。给你。你知道，我还说，你能再给我一个药瓶吗？因为我剩下的尿太多了。你给我的药瓶装不下所有的尿，所以我手里还剩下一杯。
You could see like already the horror was setting in, like, no, that's fine. I just need the one vial. I don't need two vials of urine. And I said, well, I need another vial because I have this urine. What am I going to do with this urine?
你能看到那种惊恐的神情已经在他脸上浮现了，就像是，不，不用了，没关系。我只需要一个药瓶。我不需要两瓶尿。我说，好吧，但我需要另一个药瓶，因为我这儿还有尿呢。我该拿这些尿怎么办？
And he was just like, ah, get it out of here. Throw it out. What are you--? And I just acted really flustered and then finally, you know, drank it, because I thought, you know, there's nothing else I could possibly do with this urine.
他就像是，啊，快把它拿走。扔掉它。你到底在干什么？我就装作非常慌乱的样子，最后，你知道，把它喝了，因为我想，你知道，我实在不知道还能拿这些尿怎么办。
And it was apple juice.
结果那是苹果汁。
Yeah, it was apple juice but, I mean--
对，那是苹果汁，但是，我是说……
And his reaction?
那他的反应呢？
He was just completely horrified as were the, you know, probably 5 or 10 witnesses to this. And it was really a proud moment for me. I was really happy about it.
他完全被吓坏了，在场的另外5到10个目击者也是。对我来说，那真是一个值得骄傲的时刻。我为此感到非常高兴。
And did you then have to explain, no, no, it was apple juice?
然后你不得不解释说，不不，那是苹果汁吗？
After a while. Eventually I did. I mean, I let it-- I milked the moment for all it was worth. And there were some of the residents standing around watching it happen.
过了一会儿。最终我还是说了。我的意思是，我让那一刻的价值得到了最大程度的发挥。当时还有一些住户在旁边看着这一切发生。
They must have loved you.
他们一定很喜欢你。
Yeah, I tried to keep things light.
是啊，我尽量让气氛保持轻松。
So after about a year into this job, Dave was asked if he wanted to fill in as a supervisor for an upcoming Friday night shift.
所以这份工作做了一年左右之后，有人问戴夫想不想在接下来的周五晚班替补做主管。
You know, I was excited. I thought I was being rewarded for, you know, the great job that I had been doing all this time. So I was like, oh, wow. Someone believes in me. I can be a supervisor. I felt really good about it. I'd never been supervisor of anything.
你知道，我当时很兴奋。我觉得这是对我一直以来出色表现的奖励。所以我当时想，哦，哇。有人信任我。我可以当主管了。我感觉棒极了。我以前从未做过任何人的主管。
Well, today's radio show, it's This American Life, by the way. I'm Ira Glass. Our show is from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International. Today's show, on this week when there's a new boss in Washington D.C., is all about what happens when somebody becomes the new boss.
好的，顺便说一下，今天的广播节目是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们的节目来自芝加哥公共电台和国际公共电台。今天的节目，在这个华盛顿特区迎来新老板的一周里，我们要聊聊当某人成为新老板时会发生什么。
We've got a story about a guy taking over a town where people dislike him so much, they won't even talk to him. And we've got a story from our crack economics team about the dead British guy who's about to take over the US economy. But in Dave's case at this homeless shelter, becoming a boss really meant something to him, because he was pretty young still, and growing up, he'd never been seen as very responsible.
我们有一个故事，讲的是一个人接管了一个小镇，那里的人非常讨厌他，甚至不愿意和他说话。我们还有一个来自我们顶级经济学团队的故事，讲的是那个即将接管美国经济的已故英国人。但在戴夫在无家可归者收容所的那个案例里，成为主管对他来说意义重大，因为他当时还很年轻，而且在成长过程中，他从未被视为一个有责任感的人。
And so I showed up for my shift which was an 11 to 7-- 11 at night to 7 in the morning shift. I showed up a little early just to gear up, you know.
于是我按时去上我的班，那是11点到7点的班——晚上11点到早上7点。我提前了一点到，为了做好准备。
And what does it mean? Like suddenly you're the boss. Like, what do you do as the new boss?
那意味着什么？就像你突然成了老板。你作为新老板要做什么？
You have keys to everything, which I was excited about. It was like a big chain of keys, like, you know, like if you were a superintendent of an apartment. I was looking forward to that. And you tell people when to do bed checks.
你可以掌管所有的钥匙，我对此很兴奋。那是一大串钥匙，就像你是公寓管理员一样。我很期待那个。而且你还要告诉别人什么时候去查房。
Everything was going smoothly. I was walking around with my keys. It was sort of a nice feeling. I sort of threw my shoulders back a little bit, you know. You know, I don't think I was getting power mad. I tried to be, you know, as benevolent of a supervisor as I could. But, you know, everything I'm saying, I'm talking about like 45 minutes into it.
一切进展顺利。我带着钥匙到处走动。那种感觉挺好的。我稍微挺了挺胸，你知道。我不觉得我变得权欲熏心了。我尽量做一个尽可能仁慈的主管。但是，你知道，我所说的一切，指的是上班大概45分钟后的情况。
Oh, really? 45 minutes into it.
哦，真的吗？才45分钟。
Everything I've just said is really just the first 45 minutes on the job-- all of these things that went through my mind and all these things that happened and didn't happen.
我刚才所说的所有这些事情，其实都只是上班的前45分钟——所有在我脑海中闪过的念头，以及所有发生的和没发生的事情。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So it's about one in the morning on my inaugural supervisor shift. And the weekend cook comes in, and I had worked with him many times before and, you know, was very friendly with him. And so he came in.
所以大概凌晨一点，在我的首次主管轮班时。周末厨师来了，我和他以前共事过很多次，你知道，和他关系很好。于是他进来了。
And he said, hey, Dave, can I borrow the keys? He's like, I just want to get some meat out of the freezer. And it didn't seem strange to me, because this is a guy who prepares several meals for a couple hundred people a day, you know.
他说，嘿，戴夫，能借我用一下钥匙吗？他说，我只是想从冰柜里拿点肉。这对我来说看起来并不奇怪，因为这是一个每天为几百人准备几顿饭的家伙，你知道。
Oh, you thought he just needed to defrost some meat for the next day.
哦，你以为他只是需要为第二天解冻一些肉。
Yeah, it didn't seem weird. I thought, oh, he's just getting a jump on things, you know. So I said, sure, here's the keys. He disappeared for 10 or 15 minutes and then came back and said, thanks, Dave, here you go. And he gave me the keys back. And I went home and I thought great, like, you know, my first supervisor shift went pretty well.
对，这看起来不奇怪。我想，哦，他只是在提前准备，你知道。所以我说，没问题，钥匙给你。他消失了10到15分钟，然后回来对我说，谢谢，戴夫，还给你。他把钥匙还给了我。我回家后心想，太棒了，你知道，我的第一次主管轮班进行得相当顺利。
And I walked in the next day and the security guard was sitting there. I said, hey, Al, how's it going? And he said, good. Hey, did you hear what happened, you know, with the cook last night? I'm like, what are you talking about? And he said, oh, he stole 300 pounds of beef last night. And, you know, I pretended not to have any idea how that might happen.
第二天我走进去，保安正坐在那儿。我说，嘿，艾尔，怎么样？他说，挺好。嘿，你听说昨晚厨师出什么事了吗？我说，你在说什么？他说，哦，他昨晚偷了300磅牛肉。你知道，我假装根本不知道是怎么回事。
I was like, what? You're kidding. What are you talking about? And he's like, yeah, apparently he got keys to the freezer and went down there and took out 300 pounds of meat. He took it all out and threw it over the fence to his buddy.
我当时说，什么？你开玩笑吧。你在说什么？他说，对，显然他拿到了冰柜的钥匙，下去拿走了300磅肉。他把肉全部拿出来，扔过栅栏给了他的哥们儿。
And I was going like, what? Why would anyone have a need for 300 pounds of meat at 1 AM on a Friday? And he's like, well, to sell it. I'm like, why would anyone-- what do you  mean, sell it? He's like, sell it on the street for crack.
我当时就问，什么？为什么会有人在周五凌晨1点需要300磅肉？他说，好吧，为了卖掉它们。我说，为什么会有人——什么意思，卖掉它们？他说，在街上卖掉它们换快克毒品。
None of this was making any sense to me and he's like, he's a crack head. And I'm like, what? What are you talking about? He's like, well, yeah, he's a crack addict. He was like a recovering crack-- well, now he's, I guess, full on back to being a crack head, but he was working there as a recovering crack addict. And then he starts going down the line and he's like, well, yeah, this guy's a crack addict, this guy's a crack addict. Like program aids, supervisors, security guards.
这一切对我来说根本讲不通，他说，他是个吸毒鬼。我说，什么？你在说什么？他说，噢，对，他是个快克瘾君子。他以前好像是个康复中的……嗯，现在我想，他完全回到了吸毒的状态，但他在这里工作时是以快克瘾君子康复者的身份。然后他开始列举，他说，噢，是啊，那个家伙也是个快克瘾君子，那个人也是。比如项目助理、主管、保安。
People who have your job.
和你做一样工作的人。
Yeah. And he was just going down the line. He's like, yeah, he's a crack addict. And then he starts explaining. He's like, don't you remember when he didn't show up for work that one day. Yeah, they found her, you know, turning tricks down the block for crack. And, you know, there was another guy I noticed just didn't work there anymore and they're like, yeah, they found him in the basement smoking crack on his shift. And he's just going down the line, naming all these people, and breaking it down for me on my coworkers. And finally he's like, I'm a crack head. I mean, he's not currently, but he's like-- And it was just like what?
是啊。他一个接一个地数。他说，是啊，他是个吸毒鬼。然后他开始解释。他说，你不记得他有一次没来上班吗？是的，他们发现她在街区那边为了买毒品而卖淫。还有，你知道，我注意到另一个人也不在那儿工作了，他们说，是啊，他们发现他在轮班时在地下室吸食快克。他就在那儿一个接一个地数，点出所有这些人，向我揭露我的同事们的情况。最后他说，我也是个吸毒鬼。我是说，他现在不是了，但他就像是——当时的感觉就像是，什么？
I felt foolish and I felt kind of betrayed and then sort of wondering what was going to happen. Like, am I in turn going to have to score 300 pounds of meat to make things right? You know? I just sold the movie rights to this story when I made that twist, actually. And now he must score 300 pounds of meat, using any means he can. Boom.
我感到很愚蠢，也感到一种被背叛的感觉，然后开始怀疑会发生什么。比如，我是否必须想办法弄到300磅肉来补救？你知道？其实我在做那个转折时，就把这个故事的电影版权卖掉了。现在他必须想尽一切办法弄到300磅肉。砰。
If only you could find some, like, retired thief who's just willing to do one last score with you.
要是你能找到某个退休的小偷，愿意陪你最后干一票就好了。
I told you, Dave, I'm out of the game. What'd you say? Actually it sounds like it might be kind of fun. Tell you what, I got the itch. I've been looking to get a taste of that frozen meat action for a while now. Glad you called.
我跟你说过，戴夫，我金盆洗手了。你说什么？其实听起来可能挺好玩的。跟你说吧，我手痒了。我一直想找机会尝尝那种冷冻肉的刺激。很高兴你打电话给我。
And so how long did you last as the new supervisor?
那你做新主管坚持了多久？
That was it. I was never asked to be supervisor again.
就那一次。我再也没被要求做过主管。
Did you feel bad, like oh, you let people down?
你当时感觉糟糕吗？比如，哦，你让大家失望了？
Yeah, yeah, totally. I felt really bad about it, because 300 pounds of meat, that's a lot of-- any way you slice it, that's a lot of meat to lose. So I felt bad about that because it's a homeless shelter. I definitely cost them money. I was embarrassed about it and knowing that people knew, I thought that people must look at me differently there. Or maybe they looked to me exactly as they always had, which was maybe worse.
是啊，完全是。我对此感觉非常糟糕，因为300磅肉，那可是——不管怎么算，损失这么多肉都是很大的事。所以我因为那个感觉很糟，因为它是一个无家可归者收容所。我肯定让他们损失了金钱。我对此感到尴尬，而且知道人们都知道这事，我心想大家肯定会用不同的眼光看我。或者也许他们看我的眼光和我一直以来一样，这可能更糟糕。
It simply confirmed what they--
这只会证实了他们对你的看法……
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Dave Hill. These days he is the star of a late night TV talk show that doesn't actually air on television but on stage at the UCB Theatre in New York City. It is called the Dave Hill Explosion. His website, davehillonline.com.
戴夫·希尔。如今他是深夜电视脱口秀的明星，虽然节目并没有在电视台播出，而是在纽约市UCB剧院的舞台上表演。它叫《戴夫·希尔大爆炸》。他的网站是davehillonline.com。
Act Two, A Trust Without Trust. You may have heard of Warren Jeffs. Back in 2006 he was all over the news, a religious leader running from the law. "Prophet on the lamb," one Arizona newspaper called him.
第二幕，一种没有信任的信任。你可能听说过沃伦·杰夫斯。2006年，他到处都是新闻，是一位被法律通缉的宗教领袖。亚利桑那州的一家报纸称他为“在逃的先知”。
Jeffs was the head of a fringe group of Mormons called the FLDS, Fundamentalist Church of Jesus Christ of Latter Day Saints. Unlike regular Mormons, FLDS members practice polygamy, which has been technically illegal since 1878, but it's a crime that's rarely prosecuted.
杰夫斯是摩门教一个边缘分支团体FLDS的首领，全称是“耶稣基督后期圣徒基本教义派”。与正统摩门教徒不同，FLDS成员实行一夫多妻制，这种行为自1878年起在法律上就是非法的，但这种罪行很少被起诉。
For a century, the group lived in relative anonymity out in the Utah desert but then Jeffs came to power and everything went haywire. Jeffs is accused of excommunicating members at whim, sexually abusing young children, and marrying off young girls to older men. He has followers in enclaves all over North America, including that polygamist compound in Texas that was all over the news this spring.
一个世纪以来，这个群体在犹他州沙漠中过着相对默默无闻的生活，但随后杰夫斯掌权，一切都乱套了。杰夫斯被指控随意将成员逐出教会、对年幼儿童进行性虐待，并将年轻女孩许配给年长男子。他在北美各地都有追随者，包括今年春天频频出现在新闻头条的那个德克萨斯州一夫多妻制大院。
Jeffs was caught after a year on the run, put on trial as an accomplice to rape, and sentenced to 10 years to life in prison. When he was arrested in 2005, he's said to have had over 100 wives. But after Jeffs was locked up, a much thornier issue presented itself, what to do with all the property owned by the church that he led, the FLDS.
杰夫斯在逃亡一年后被抓获，作为强奸帮凶受审，被判处10年到终身监禁。当他于2005年被捕时，据说他有100多位妻子。但在杰夫斯被关起来之后，一个更棘手的问题出现了：如何处理他所领导的教会——FLDS——拥有的所有财产。
It is not a small matter. For over 70 years, FLDS members had given huge chunks of their income and all their houses, businesses, farms, animals-- all their assets-- to this church trust, which is called the United Effort Plan, the UEP.
这不是一件小事。70多年来，FLDS成员将他们收入的一大部分，以及他们所有的房屋、企业、农场、动物——所有资产——都捐给了这个名为“联合努力计划”（UEP）的教会信托机构。
Total value of the UEP? Over $112 million. And Warren Jeffs was the person who managed that money. But when Jeffs became a fugitive, he started to liquidate land in the trust, putting it up for sale at a fraction of its real cost to fund the things that he was doing, and the Utah Attorney General stepped in.
UEP的总价值？超过1.12亿美元。沃伦·杰夫斯就是管理这笔钱的人。但当杰夫斯成为逃犯时，他开始清算信托中的土地，以其实际价值的一小部分将其出售，来资助他正在进行的那些勾当，于是犹他州总检察长介入了。
The state decided to put the UEP in the hands of a regular old accountant, somebody who had nothing to do with the FLDS, somebody legally qualified to manage the trust in the way that most trusts are managed, in the best interests of the members who paid into it in the first place.
州政府决定将UEP交给一个普通的会计师管理，一个与FLDS毫无瓜葛的人，一个在法律上有资格以大多数信托的管理方式来管理该信托的人，以维护最初出资成员的最佳利益。
And that is how Bruce Wisan got the job. He was the trust's new boss, suddenly managing the money of a community full of people who did not want him managing their money. Claire Hoffman tells what happened.
这就是布鲁斯·威桑得到这份工作的原因。他是信托的新老板，突然间要管理一个充满了不想让他管理其钱财的人的社区。克莱尔·霍夫曼讲述了发生的事情。
Bruce didn't quite know what he was getting into when he took this job in 2005, but he was used to people not liking him. Bruce runs a large accounting firm in Salt Lake City but he has a side career in rescuing distressed assets. It's like being a repo man on a bigger scale.
布鲁斯在2005年接受这份工作时，并不完全知道自己卷入了什么，但他习惯了人们不喜欢他。布鲁斯在盐湖城经营着一家大型会计师事务所，但他还有一个副业，就是拯救陷入困境的资产。这就像是大规模的抵押品赎回人。
The state of Utah has hired him to manage all kinds of businesses on the verge of bankruptcy. He ran a motel, a bowling alley, a warehouse, a Subway sandwich shop. At one point, he took over a bankrupt bar and ran that, even though he doesn't drink. But the UEP was going to be a lot harder.
犹他州政府雇佣他去管理各种濒临破产的企业。他经营过一家汽车旅馆、一家保龄球馆、一个仓库、一家赛百味三明治店。有一次，他接管了一家破产酒吧并经营它，尽管他自己并不喝酒。但UEP要困难得多。
The Attorney General's office said, we really don't have any blueprint for you. This is uncharted territory. You're going in to manage the real estate of thousands of people that are going to look at this as a government takeover, that it's going to be hostile. And they're not going to like you. We don't know what kind of reaction they're going to give you. I mean, there are just a lot of unknowns and uncertainties.
总检察长办公室说，我们真的没有给你任何蓝图。这是未知的领域。你进去是为了管理成千上万人的房地产，这些人会把它看作是政府接管，这会是敌对的。而且他们不会喜欢你。我们不知道他们会给你什么样的反应。我是说，有太多的未知数和不确定性。
Unknowns and uncertainties is an understatement. The community of Short Creek had fallen apart. For years, Warren Jeffs had predicted the end of the world every six months and so people had stopped construction on their homes and stopped fixing things when they broke. Businesses moved out of town.
未知数和不确定性简直是轻描淡写的说法。肖特克里克社区已经分崩离析了。多年来，沃伦·杰夫斯每隔六个月就会预测一次世界末日，所以人们停止了房屋建设，东西坏了也不再修理。企业纷纷迁出小镇。
In addition, there was a rising tide of litigation against Warren Jeffs and the church by underage brides and other former FLDS members. If they won their lawsuits, they could be awarded millions of dollars in damages and that money could come out of the UEP trust. People's homes in Short Creek would have to be sold off to pay for that.
此外，针对沃伦·杰夫斯和教会的诉讼浪潮不断高涨，原告包括未成年新娘和其他前FLDS成员。如果她们赢了官司，她们可能会获得数百万美元的赔偿，而这些钱可能来自UEP信托。肖特克里克的民众房屋将不得不被变卖来支付这些赔偿。
So it was Bruce's job to fight to protect the assets of the trust from these kinds of judgments. He had to convince the courts that even if what Jeffs had done was wrong, awards shouldn't be paid out of the trust. And if all that weren't daunting enough, Bruce had to get past the first hurdle.
所以布鲁斯的工作是努力保护信托资产免受这类判决的侵害。他必须说服法院，即使杰夫斯所做的是错误的，赔偿也不应该从信托中支付。如果这一切还不够艰巨，布鲁斯还得跨越第一个障碍。
Their leader, Warren Jeffs, told the people to literally ignore me, that I didn't exist. If I knock on their doors, they're not going to open the doors. We'd put letters in every post office box in town and the post office would often say that the floor would be littered with my correspondence because they were told not to even read anything that I said. So I didn't have a lot of opportunity to meet the average member.
他们的领袖沃伦·杰夫斯告诉大家字面上忽略我，我就像不存在一样。如果我敲他们的门，他们不会开门。我们把信件投进镇上每一个邮箱，邮局通常会说地板上会散落着我的信件，因为他们被告知甚至不要读我写的任何东西。所以我没有太多机会见到普通成员。
On Bruce's early trips to Short Creek, women would grab their children and rush inside to avoid him. They wouldn't serve him in the ice cream shop. He would often be tailed by law enforcement. The local police were still tools of the FLDS.
布鲁斯早期前往肖特克里克时，妇女们会抓起孩子冲进屋内以避开他。她们不会在冰淇淋店为他提供服务。他经常被执法部门跟踪。当地警察仍然是FLDS的工具。
Being a mainstream Mormon himself, Bruce had always heard about the fundamentalist polygamists living out in the desert. And like most mainstream Mormons, he didn't think too highly of them. But now he wanted to help, especially when it came to people's homes.
布鲁斯本人是主流摩门教徒，他一直听说过生活在沙漠里的原教旨主义一夫多妻者。像大多数主流摩门教徒一样，他并没有把他们看得很重。但现在他想提供帮助，特别是在人们的住房方面。
No one in Short Creek had a deed to their own home. Their houses were communal property owned by the church. In fact, this was the biggest part of the UEP trust, people's homes. But without deeds to their own homes, everyone lived at the whim of church leaders who could decide in a day whether you were entitled to live in your own house or not.
肖特克里克没有人拥有自己住房的房契。他们的房子是教会拥有的公共财产。事实上，这是UEP信托中最大的一部分，就是人们的家。但没有自己住房的房契，每个人都生活在教会领袖的摆布下，他们可以一天之内就决定你是否有权住进你自己的房子里。
When Warren Jeffs came into power, there were a lot of families that were disrupted. He moved a lot of people from house to house. He expelled a lot of men, reassigned their wives and children to other men.
当沃伦·杰夫斯掌权时，许多家庭被破坏了。他把很多人搬来搬去。他驱逐了许多男人，把他们的妻子和孩子重新分配给其他男人。
I spoke with a young girl that left the community. She was on one of those moving crews and she said that they could go into a house at night-- usually 2 or 3 o'clock in the morning-- and they would move the whole house in less than an hour. And they would go in and Saran wrap the dressers and desks and whatever. Things weren't packed in boxes. Even the next door neighbors wouldn't know until the next morning that somebody new was living in the house.
我和一个离开社区的年轻女孩交谈过。她是那些搬迁工作组的一员，她说他们可以在晚上——通常是凌晨2点或3点——进入一间房子，不到一小时就能搬空整间房子。他们进去用保鲜膜包好梳妆台、书桌什么的。东西都没有装箱。甚至连隔壁邻居也要等到第二天早上才知道有人搬进来了。
Many of the people Warren Jeffs excommunicated from the church still live in the area. They were the first ones to open their doors to Bruce, offering help and advice. Bruce has hired several of them to help him, like Jethro Barlow. A trained accountant, Jethro has lived here his whole life and was a member of the FLDS for most of it until a few years ago, when he was excommunicated. Then his house was taken from him and the church ordered both his wives to leave him.
许多被沃伦·杰夫斯逐出教会的人仍然住在这个地区。他们是第一批向布鲁斯敞开大门的人，提供帮助和建议。布鲁斯雇佣了其中几个人来帮忙，比如杰思罗·巴洛。杰思罗是一位训练有素的会计师，他一生都住在这里，绝大部分时间都是FLDS的成员，直到几年前他被驱逐。然后他的房子被没收，教会命令他的两个妻子都离开他。
I'm in a situation right now where I have children that I haven't seen or spoken to in years. One of them lives right across the street, kitty corner from me, and I haven't spoken to him since I moved back to the community. My mother is in one of these big walled compounds over here. I can't visit her.
我现在处于一种情况，我有一些孩子已经几年没见也没说过话了。其中一个就住在街对面，就在我斜对面，我搬回社区后还没和他讲过话。我母亲就在这里面那座高墙大院里。我没法探望她。
Jethro says he was one of the first of the 200 men to be expelled from the FLDS under Warren Jeffs. He doesn't know why. At that point, Warren Jeffs was kicking men out because of the tiniest of infractions. By the end, if Jeffs had a bad dream and the dream showed you not to be righteous, that was enough to get you evicted. And so without warning or explanation, Jethro was expected to leave his community and the life he knew.
杰思罗说他是沃伦·杰夫斯统治下被逐出FLDS的首批200名男性之一。他不知道原因。在那个阶段，沃伦·杰夫斯仅仅因为最小的违规行为就把男人踢出去。到最后，如果杰夫斯做了一个噩梦，梦见你不虔诚，那就足以把你赶出去了。所以没有任何警告或解释，杰思罗就得离开他的社区和他所知的生活。
Like a Taliban coming into Afghanistan, there was just every week another fatwa that was issued about color of hair, what you could eat, what color you could wear, meetings that had to be attended to, et cetera, et cetera.
就像塔利班进入阿富汗一样，每周都会发布另一项关于头发颜色、你能吃什么、你能穿什么颜色、必须参加的会议等等的教令。
Then the church became more and more intrusive into people's lives. And as those few people who dissented or resisted or had a different opinion-- in fact, the entire older generation. Over 200 heads of families have been dispatched from the community and sent away.
然后教会越来越深入地干预人们的生活。随着那些持不同意见或抵抗者或有不同想法的人——事实上，整整一代老一辈。超过200名户主被遣散出了社区，被送走。
One time I was down in the community. We were in Jethro's truck.
有一次我在社区里。我们坐在杰思罗的卡车上。
Again, Bruce Wisan.
依然是布鲁斯·威桑。
Just driving slowly in a pickup truck. And a young mother with two small children were walking on a sidewalk and she smiled and gave a casual wave to us as we drove by. We were only driving like 10 or 15 miles an hour. And she didn't really look at us. She didn't know who we were.
只是在一辆皮卡车里慢慢开着。一位带着两个小孩的年轻母亲正走在人行道上，她笑了笑，在我们经过时随手挥了挥。我们当时只开着每小时10到15英里的速度。她并没有真正看我们。她不知道我们是谁。
And I commented to Jethro. I said, oh, isn't that nice? And he stopped the truck and put his hands over the steering wheel and put his head down. And he said, that was one of my daughters and those were two of my grandchildren that I've never met.
我评论说，哦，那不是很友好吗？杰思罗停下卡车，把手放在方向盘上，低下头。他说，那是我女儿之一，那是两个我从未见过面的外孙。
And I said, Jethro, go back. Why don't you go back and talk to her and see them then? And he said, oh, I would give anything to do that, but it would cause so many problems that I don't think I should.
我说，杰思罗，回去吧。为什么你不回去跟她说话，然后见见他们？他说，哦，我愿意付出一切去做那件事，但这会引起太多的问题，我觉得我不应该那么做。
And it wasn't that it would cause problems for him. It would cause problems for her if she were to be seen speaking with an apostate, even though it's her father and even though those grandkids had never seen or visited with their grandfather. And those are tragic, tragic situations.
并不是说这会给他造成问题。如果她被看到和一个叛教者说话，那会给她造成问题，即使那是她父亲，即使那些外孙从来没见过或探望过他们的祖父。那些都是极其悲惨的情况。
Fixing these tragic situations would seem to be beyond the power of an accountant, but incredibly, Bruce Wisan thinks it isn't. And so early on, he decided the best thing he could do for Jethro and everyone else here was to give them their homes. The houses would no longer be owned by the trust. Bruce and the Utah court saw this as simple justice.
解决这些悲剧性情况似乎超出了会计师的能力，但令人难以置信的是，布鲁斯·威桑认为并非如此。所以很早的时候，他就决定他能为杰思罗和这里所有人做的最好的事，就是把房子给他们。房子将不再由信托机构拥有。布鲁斯和犹他州法院认为这是一种简单的公正。
For decades, people like Jethro paid a hefty chunk of their income to the trust. Now they get the titles to their houses in return. The 15% of the community Bruce estimates are excommunicated would finally have real independence from the church, which they've wanted.
几十年来，像杰思罗这样的人把收入的一大部分贡献给了信托。现在他们以此换取了房屋的所有权。布鲁斯估计社区中15%的被驱逐者终于可以获得他们一直渴望的、真正的教会独立。
But for everyone else, the families who are still in the FLDS, it would have a side effect the courts and Bruce don't like to talk about much or advertise. A side effect that FLDS families find frightening and threatening to their way of life. It would give the church less control over them.
但对于其他人，那些仍然在FLDS中的家庭，这会产生一个法院和布鲁斯不太愿意多谈或宣传的副作用。一个FLDS家庭感到恐惧并威胁到他们生活方式的副作用。这会使教会对他们的控制力减弱。
So in a way, owning a home is a way for them to disentangle themselves from the tentacles of Warren Jeffs.
所以从某种意义上说，拥有一处住房是他们将自己与沃伦·杰夫斯的触手剥离的一种方式。
Yes, it is a way if somebody wants to, as you say, untangle themselves from Warren Jeffs and some of the strange doctrine that he's preached. Yeah, this would be the time to do it and this would be the way to do it.
是的，如果有人想要，正如你所说，从沃伦·杰夫斯和他传教的一些奇怪教义中剥离出来。是的，现在就是做这件事的时候，这也是做这件事的方法。
So this is really the main part of town. The police station and city hall for Colorado City is right there.
所以这就是镇上的主要部分。科罗拉多城的警察局和市政厅就在那里。
Bruce takes me down to Short Creek for a tour. Short Creek is made up of the twin cities of Colorado City, Arizona, and Hildale, Utah. Driving around, the lack of color, signs, advertising is shocking. Everything is gray and white and brown.
布鲁斯带我去肖特克里克参观。肖特克里克由亚利桑那州的科罗拉多城和犹他州的希尔代尔这对双子城组成。开车绕行时，这里缺乏色彩、标志和广告令人震惊。一切都是灰色、白色和棕色的。
It doesn't look like America, or at least not America in this century. Part of that is because Warren Jeffs got really into banishing things, all sorts of things, like the color red. He outlawed stripes and dogs, killing off hundreds, movies, books, TV. He dismantled the library.
这看起来不像是美国，或者至少不是这个世纪的美国。部分原因是沃伦·杰夫斯非常热衷于禁止东西，各种各样的东西，比如红色。他禁止了条纹和狗——杀死了数百条狗、电影、书籍、电视。他拆除了图书馆。
We pass a four-wheel motorcycle with five teenage girls piled on, in ornate old fashioned hairdos and prairie dresses driving down the road. It's hard not to stare but then again, in this area, our car is a spectacle.
我们经过一辆四轮摩托车，上面挤着五个十几岁的女孩，梳着华丽的老式发型，穿着平原风格的连衣裙在路上行驶。很难不盯着看，但话说回来，在这个地区，我们的车本身就是一个奇观。
And they know we're outsiders because I have short sleeves and your hair isn't done up in the normal way.
而且她们知道我们是局外人，因为我穿着短袖，你的头发也没有按正常方式打理。
This is an odd place. The homes are massive. They have to be to house all those wives and those dozens of children.
这是一个奇怪的地方。房子很大。它们必须得足够大，才能容纳所有那些妻子和几十个孩子。
This is where Warren Jeffs lived.
这就是沃伦·杰夫斯住的地方。
Warren Jeffs's compound takes up a city block and it was there that allegedly he lived with over 100 of his wives. But many of their homes around town are unfinished, missing roofs, walls, windows. This is the construction that never got completed because of all those predictions of the apocalypse. Most of the streets were dirt.
沃伦·杰夫斯的宅邸占据了一个街区，据说他就是在那儿和他的100多位妻子生活在一起的。但镇上许多房屋都还没盖好，缺屋顶、墙壁、窗户。这就是那些因为末日预言而从未完成的建设。大多数街道都是泥土路。
When Bruce took over, the trust owed almost $2 million in back property taxes, which he started paying off. Then he pushed the city government to make long needed repairs to community property, like paving the roads, getting fire hydrants installed, improving the water and sewer system, renovating the town park.
当布鲁斯接管时，信托欠了近200万美元的拖欠房产税，他开始偿还这些税款。然后他推动市政府对社区财产进行亟需的修缮，比如铺设道路、安装消防栓、改善供水和排污系统、翻新城镇公园。
Even here there was resistance, because his overall agenda was clear to everyone. He wanted to make the town government, the police, the utilities all function the way they function in other towns, as secular neutral institutions no longer under church control.
即便是这里也有抵触情绪，因为他的总体议程对每个人来说都很清楚。他想让镇政府、警察、公用事业机构都像其他城镇一样运行，成为不再受教会控制的世俗中立机构。
They battled me, the cities especially-- the city councils, the city water people, city engineers, all of those people covertly opposed what I'm doing. They don't argue with me. They don't debate with me. They just tell me they're going to do something and then don't do it, or tell me that I can't do something because of some new requirement that they've just thought up.
他们与我作战，特别是这些城市——市议会、城市供水部门、城市工程师，所有这些人都在秘密地反对我所做的事。他们不跟我争论。他们不跟我辩论。他们只是告诉我他们会做某事，然后就不做了，或者告诉我说由于他们刚想出的某个新要求，我不能做某事。
He has destroyed and attempted to destroy every good thing in the community.
他摧毁并试图摧毁社区里的每一件好事。
That's Willie Jessop. With Warren Jeffs in prison, it's not exactly clear who's running the FLDS now, but Willie Jessop has emerged and taken the spotlight as spokesman and point person for the FLDS, standing up against the outsiders, the feds, and the state. And no one seems to disgust Jessop more than Bruce.
那是威利·杰索普。随着沃伦·杰夫斯入狱，现在究竟是谁在掌管FLDS并不清楚，但威利·杰索普已经站了出来，作为FLDS的发言人和联络人占据了焦点，对抗局外人、联邦政府和州政府。似乎没有人比布鲁斯更让杰索普厌恶。
There is not words in the English language that I have found that can describe what Bruce Wisan has done to this community. There isn't words to describe the harm that he has done to people.
我找不到英语单词来描述布鲁斯·威桑对这个社区所做的事情。没有语言能描述他给人们造成的伤害。
He launched a full set attack, with this judge's help, on our police department, on our city governments, our water companies, our municipalities. He'll have to be accountable to someone a lot greater than us for what he's done.
他在法官的帮助下，对我们的警察局、市政府、自来水公司、市政当局发动了全面攻击。对于他所做的一切，他将不得不向比我们伟大得多的人负责。
To Jessop, Bruce is a bad man who's out to destroy the polygamists' faith. He tells me that Bruce first came into the community proclaiming himself the state appointed bishop. Since then, Jessop says, Bruce has tried to take apart every bit of structure their community has and to profit mightily along the way.
对杰索普来说，布鲁斯是一个试图摧毁一夫多妻者信仰的坏人。他告诉我，布鲁斯第一次来到社区时，宣称自己是州任命的主教。从那时起，杰索普说，布鲁斯就试图拆解社区结构的每一部分，并在此过程中牟取暴利。
I think he made his stand very quick by the people he employed and he only reached out publicly. He'd show up to the city hall meeting and tell everybody how he only wanted to reach out to the community, but then he would only seek the interest of those that were hateful, known hateful against us.
我认为他通过他雇佣的人很快就表明了立场，而且他只公开接触。他会出现在市政厅会议上，告诉所有人他只想接触社区，但随后他只会寻求那些仇恨我们的人的利益。
What I was going to say when you started the town hall meetings, his point is, I had town hall meetings. Nobody showed up and the only people who showed up were the people who were kicked out. So those are the people who engaged with me. And that would be his explanation.
当你开始市政厅会议时，我要说的是，他的观点是，我举行过市政厅会议。没有人到场，唯一到场的人是被踢出教会的人。所以那些是与我互动的人。那将是他的解释。
Well, how could anybody say-- well, if nobody shows up and you're supposed to be helping them, something must not be right. But rather than fix it, he just kept doing it. And then the more he can say how uncooperative it is, he can justify larger lawyer bills to pay himself and bigger accounting fees to pay himself. There's a huge conflict of interest. Does he really want to solve the problems when he gets every penny of the problem that he generates? Come on.
好吧，怎么会有人说——好吧，如果没有人到场而你本应是在帮助他们，那肯定有什么不对劲。但与其解决问题，他只是继续这样做。然后他越能说这里是多么的不配合，他就可以证明更高的律师费来支付自己，以及更大的会计费用来支付自己。这里存在巨大的利益冲突。当他从他制造的每一个问题中获得每一分钱时，他真的想解决这些问题吗？得了吧。
Bruce's fees are a source of real bitterness here. They've totaled more than $600,000. In addition, to protect the trust's assets from being seized in lawsuits against Warren Jeffs, Bruce has spent over $1 million on lawyers.
布鲁斯的费用在这里是真正痛苦的源头。它们总计超过60万美元。此外，为了保护信托资产免受针对沃伦·杰夫斯的诉讼的扣押，布鲁斯在律师身上花了100多万美元。
To pay for all that, he's selling off trust property, including an office building and some plots of land. He's also asked every Short Creek resident to pay $100 every month to fund city improvements and the administration of the trust.
为了支付这一切，他正在变卖信托财产，包括一栋办公大楼和一些土地。他还要求肖特克里克的每位居民每月支付100美元来资助城市改善和信托的管理。
The way Jessop sees it, that's just stealing from FLDS members. But of all the things that Bruce has tried to do, nothing angers Jessop more than his attempt to privatize the land and create individual home ownership.
在杰索普看来，那简直就是在从FLDS成员身上偷钱。但在布鲁斯试图做的所有事情中，没有比他试图将土地私有化和建立个人住房所有权更让杰索普愤怒的了。
If I want my home to be held in the way that I believe, which is that we put our homes and we pull them together in a united order, that's how we got them. That's how we built them. That's how we consecrated them.
如果我希望我的家按照我认为的方式持有，也就是我们将我们的家放在一起并联合起来，我们就是那样获得它们的。我们就是那样建造它们的。我们就是那样奉献它们的。
And if somebody comes and says, I'm going to break your church up and give you your home and I don't want him to, what is he doing it for? Why do you want to give me a title to something that I believe belongs to the community and to heavenly father and to us as a whole? Why do that? Why force me to do that?
如果有人来，说我要拆散你的教会，把你的家给你，而我不想要，他这么做是为了什么？为什么你要给我一个我认为属于社区、属于天父、属于我们作为一个整体的东西的头衔？为什么要那样做？为什么强迫我那样做？
Why do you think he wants to do that?
你认为他为什么要那样做？
Psychological and sociological warfare against the FLDS. And he's got the state of Utah giving him the authority to do it.
针对FLDS的心理和社会战。而且他有犹他州政府授予他这么做的权力。
This point's the impossibility of Bruce's job. Bruce insists that he's just an accountant looking after the assets of the trust with no other agenda, but the simple fact that he's telling the church to divide its communal property and give away houses is stepping on how people here want to practice their religion. Again, here's Willie.
这一点指出了布鲁斯工作的不可行性。布鲁斯坚持说他只是一个会计师，照顾信托资产，没有任何其他议程，但他说教会应该划分公共财产并分配房屋的事实，本身就践踏了这里的人们想要实践其宗教的方式。再次重申，这是威利的话。
It's a little bit like saying, I want to go and give everybody their brick out of a church. Well, if nobody wants the brick, why would he tear down their church? Why would somebody force me to take it? Is there anyone in the community that said, hey, I want my property subdivided in this? Any? Have you heard of any?
这有点像说，我想去把教堂里的每一块砖分给大家。好吧，如果没人想要这块砖，他为什么要拆掉他们的教堂？为什么有人要强迫我接受它？社区里有没有人说，嘿，我想把我的财产细分？有吗？你听过有任何人这样吗？
I ask him about the one group in Short Creek who definitely want their houses back from the trust, and that's the people who have been excommunicated from the church. And he surprises me by denying that anybody was kicked out of the church.
我问他关于肖特克里克那个明确想要从信托收回房子的团体，即那些被教会逐出教会的人。他让我感到惊讶，他否认了任何人曾被踢出教会。
Meanwhile, Bruce points out that regardless of their standing in the church, all these FLDS and former FLDS members are also American citizens, which means that when they paid into the trust, it gave them certain rights to their property, including owning their homes. He wants every FLDS member to know that they have that right. Since most of them have been in the church since the day they were born, it will be the first chance they ever get to exercise it.
与此同时，布鲁斯指出，无论他们在教会中的地位如何，所有这些FLDS和前FLDS成员也都是美国公民，这意味着当他们缴纳信托金时，这赋予了他们某些财产权利，包括拥有他们的房屋。他希望每一位FLDS成员都知道他们拥有这种权利。因为他们大多数人从出生那天起就一直在教会里，这将是他们第一次有机会行使这一权利。
I've been told even by FLDS-- an occasional FLDS person-- if titles are passed to the individuals, that maybe 30% of the FLDS will keep the title to their houses. So these are people that are not quite as staunch and may want this opportunity to establish some security for themselves.
我甚至被FLDS的人告诉过——偶尔有个FLDS人——如果所有权转让给个人，也许30%的FLDS会保留他们房子的所有权。所以这些人并不那么坚定，可能希望这个机会为自己建立一些保障。
Mostly, Bruce is tired and ready for this case to be over, and frustrated at all the battles that haven't gone his way.
大多时候，布鲁斯很累，准备好结束这个案子了，并对所有没能如他所愿的战斗感到沮丧。
My only ambition is to get out of this case. It's been three and a half years. My attorney and I are just exhausted and it's affected my CPA practice a lot. I probably spend 50% of my time on this case and it represents 10% of my billing. I'm spending 50% of my time on 10% of my income. That's not a very smart thing to do. And so, frankly, I would really like to see this resolved.
我唯一的野心就是从这个案子中脱身。已经三年半了。我和我的律师精疲力尽，这对我的注册会计师业务影响很大。我可能把50%的时间花在这个案子上，而它仅占我账单收入的10%。我把50%的时间花在了10%的收入上。这可不是一件很聪明的事。所以，坦率地说，我真的很想看到这件事得到解决。
Whoa.
哇。
Now where's the police station? I'm supposed to park at the police station.
现在警察局在哪里？我应该把车停在警察局。
I think the police station is--
我想警察局在……
It's on a Friday morning this past November that Bruce is driving to the county courthouse in Saint George, Utah. We turn the corner to the street of the courthouse and are greeted by hundreds and hundreds of polygamists in pastel prairie dresses and denim work clothes crammed on the sidewalks that surround the courthouse.
就在上周五11月的一个早上，布鲁斯正开车前往犹他州圣乔治的县法院。我们转弯来到法院所在的街道，迎接我们的是数百名穿着柔和色调平原连衣裙和牛仔工作服的一夫多妻者，她们挤满了法院周围的人行道。
They're eerily quiet, like something out of a movie. They're waiting for Bruce. Bruce drives briskly past as if this happens every day. Then he spots a cop on the corner and rolls down his window.
她们静得诡异，就像电影里的场景。她们在等布鲁斯。布鲁斯快速开车经过，仿佛这每天都在发生。然后他发现角落里有个警察，摇下车窗。
Where's the police station?
警察局在哪？
The police station is right across from the courthouse. A police escort has been arranged to lead Bruce into court through the back door of the building to avoid the crowd. It's been four years that Bruce has run the UEP trust, and with all the infighting, he doesn't have much to show for it except nearly a dozen lawsuits filed against him.
警察局就在法院对面。已经安排了警车护送布鲁斯通过大楼后门进入法庭以避开人群。布鲁斯管理UEP信托已经四年了，由于所有的内斗，他几乎没什么成果，除了针对他的近十起诉讼。
But today, one of them has generated a huge crowd. The church has contested Bruce's right to sell off a plot of farmland on the outskirts of town. He has to do it, he says, in order to pay the costs of running the trust. The FLDS flock is up in arms, saying the land was sacred and the future site of a temple.
但今天，其中一起诉讼引发了巨大的人群。教会对布鲁斯出售镇郊一块农地的权利提出质疑。他说他必须这样做，才能支付信托运作的成本。FLDS信徒愤慨不已，称这块土地是神圣的，是未来寺庙的所在地。
Today's hearing is an opportunity to make a show of force, to demonstrate just how opposed to Bruce they are. And they've come en masse.
今天的听证会是一个展示力量的机会，以此表明她们对布鲁斯有多么反对。她们倾巢而出。
After an hour of closed door deliberations, the judge tells the two parties she won't make a ruling for 30 days and that for now the land won't be sold. It's a rare win for the FLDS. Outside, the huge crowds smile and whisper thanks to their heavenly father for conquering Bruce.
在闭门审议一小时后，法官告诉双方她30天内不会做出裁决，并且目前这块土地不会被出售。这对FLDS来说是一次罕见的胜利。在外面，庞大的人群微笑着，低声感谢她们的天父征服了布鲁斯。
God has blessed me so much. The heavenly father will win.
上帝太保佑我了。天父会赢的。
It's very possible that someday soon, when Bruce gets deeds to their homes into the hands of all these people gathered here, church leaders will convince all of them, every last family, to hand their homes right back over to the church and a brand new trust. If that happens, Bruce says, at least they'll have had a fair chance to get what's rightly theirs. At least he'll have opened a door. He can't make them walk through it.
很有可能在不久的将来，当布鲁斯把房屋契据交到聚集在这里的所有这些人手中时，教会领袖会说服她们所有人，每一个家庭，把她们的房子直接交还给教会和一个全新的信托机构。如果发生了那种情况，布鲁斯说，至少她们曾有过一次公平的机会得到本属于她们的东西。至少他曾打开过一扇门。他无法强迫她们走进去。
Claire Hoffman lives in Los Angeles. Coming up, sex lives of the world's great economists, or of one of them, anyway. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
克莱尔·霍夫曼住在洛杉矶。接下来，世界上伟大经济学家的性生活，或者至少是其中一位的。从芝加哥公共电台和国际公共电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The New Boss.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目是《新老板》。
And before we go any further, I just want to say something about the new boss in Washington D.C., Barack Obama. And before I say this, I want to be absolutely clear with you that what you are about to hear is not the viewpoint of this public radio station, of Public Radio International, National Public Radio, or anybody else in public radio but the staff of This American Life. OK? This is something that came up at one of our editorial meetings and it is now the official editorial policy of This American Life when it comes to the Obama presidency.
在我们继续之前，我只想说一点关于华盛顿特区新老板的事，巴拉克·奥巴马。在我说这话之前，我绝对想向您澄清，您即将听到的不是这家公共电台、国际公共电台、国家公共电台，或公共广播中任何其他人的观点，而是《美国生活》员工的观点。好吗？这是我们编辑会议上提出的一个议题，现在是《美国生活》在奥巴马总统任期问题上的正式编辑政策。
Don't force him to quit smoking.
别逼他戒烟。
Our senior producer, Julie Snyder, agreed to come into the studio to discuss this.
我们的资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德同意来到演播室讨论这个问题。
The smoking is his one flaw, basically, the one sort of release valve that he has of being not perfect and not always in control and not totally responsible.
吸烟基本上是他唯一的一个缺陷，是他作为一个人——不是完美的，不是总是掌控一切的，不是完全负责任的——唯一的一个发泄出口。
Let the guy have  like one moment where he doesn't have to be on stage in his life.
让这家伙有那么一刻，他不需要站在他人生舞台上。
And so controlled and so responsible. If he doesn't have this, if we shut down this, then I'm afraid he's going to have an affair. And that's horrible and awful. You know, you would hate him. I would hate him. Everyone would hate him, justifiably so.
而且总是那么克制和负责。如果他没有这个，如果我们禁止这个，那么我担心他会出轨。那太可怕、太糟糕了。你知道，你会恨他。我会恨他。每个人都会恨他，而且是有正当理由的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You think that that's where it goes?
你认为事情会变成那样吗？
Yeah. And I know everyone's all like, oh but, you know, oh, he and Michelle and they bring romance back to the White House and they love each other so much. I totally agree. I don't think that he would have an affair because he's unhappy. I don't think it would have anything to do with Michelle. He would just have an affair because he needs like the one vice that reminds him that he is not superhuman and that he's not always just like the President, you know.
是的。而且我知道每个人都像，噢但是，你知道，噢，他和米歇尔把浪漫带回了白宫，他们彼此相爱太深了。我完全同意。我不认为他会因为不快乐而有外遇。我不认为这和米歇尔有任何关系。他只会因为他需要一个能提醒他并非超人，而且并不总是只是总统那样的恶习，你知道。
And it's not like he'd ever let himself be photographed smoking, too.
而且他也不会让自己被拍到吸烟，对吧。
That's like the thing. I know. Totally. Because I know everyone's, oh, he's like a role model and stuff like that. Like the guy's hardly going to be like boozing it up and smoking in pictures and stuff. There's no way he's going to be caught smoking.
那是重点。我知道。完全正确。因为我知道每个人都会说，噢，他是榜样之类的。这家伙几乎不可能像是在照片里喝酒吸烟之类的。他绝对不会被抓到在吸烟。
Julie Snyder is the senior producer of our program.
朱莉·斯奈德是我们节目的资深制作人。
And this brings us to Act Four of our program. Act Four, The $15 trillion Dismal Science Project. Of course, a new boss comes in with a new plan for how things should be run and one of the big parts of Barack Obama's new plan is the economic stimulus package that was passed in the House this week. It's going to be debated next week in the Senate. He's been talking about this stimulus a lot.
这把我们带到了我们节目的第四幕。第四幕，《15万亿美元的沉闷科学项目》。当然，一个新老板带着关于事情应该如何运作的新计划上任，而巴拉克·奥巴马新计划的一大组成部分就是本周在众议院通过的经济刺激方案。下周将在参议院进行辩论。他一直在谈论这个刺激方案。
Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。
This is from the big speech he gave a couple weeks ago where he explained the economic package. The House's version will cost the government over $800 billion, $800 billion of spending and tax cuts that Barack Obama says is the only thing that can help our economy right now.
这是来自他几周前发表的解释经济方案的大型演讲。众议院的版本将花费政府超过8000亿美元，8000亿美元的支出和减税，巴拉克·奥巴马说这是目前唯一能帮助我们经济的东西。
It is true that we cannot depend on government alone to create jobs or long-term growth, but at this particular moment only government can provide the short-term boost necessary to lift us from a recession this deep and severe. Only government can break the cycle that are crippling our economy, where a lack of spending leads to lost jobs which leads to even less spending, where an inability to lend and borrow stops growth and leads to even less credit.
确实，我们不能单靠政府来创造就业或长期增长，但在此时此刻，只有政府能够提供走出如此深度和严重衰退所需的短期推动力。只有政府能够打破导致我们经济瘫痪的循环，即缺乏支出导致失业，进而导致支出减少，缺乏借贷能力阻止增长，进而导致信贷进一步减少。
His plan would rebuild roads and bridges, double the production of alternative energy, expand access to the internet, and do all kinds of other things.
他的计划将重建道路和桥梁，增加替代能源生产，扩大互联网接入，并做各种其他事情。
It's a plan that represents not just new policy, but a whole new approach to meeting our most urgent challenges.
这不仅仅代表了一项新政策，更是一种迎接我们最紧迫挑战的全新方法。
In fact, much of the President's plan comes straight out of a very old playbook, a playbook developed before World War II, in fact, in the depths of the Great Depression by a foul-mouthed, slutty British elitist, who was called arrogant, supercilious, unbearably boorish. And that's by his friends. His enemies, man, they really hated him.
事实上，总统计划的大部分内容直接来自一本非常古老的剧本，一本在二战前，事实上是在大萧条时期由一位满口脏话、放荡的英国精英编写的剧本，他被称为傲慢、目中无人、不可理喻的粗野。那是他的朋友们对他的评价。至于他的敌人，天哪，他们真的很恨他。
He's one of the great economists of the 20th century and you've probably heard his name, John Maynard Keynes. The team that brings us our economic stories here on This American Life-- that's our producer, Alex Blumberg, and NPR economics correspondent, Adam Davidson-- have this story about him and his playbook.
他是20世纪伟大的经济学家之一，你可能听说过他的名字，约翰·梅纳德·凯恩斯。在这个《美国生活》中为我们带来经济故事的团队——那是我们的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格和NPR经济通讯记者亚当·戴维森——有关于他和他的剧本的故事。
Keynes published his big theory-- the theory underpinning President Obama's fiscal stimulus-- in 1936. And many would argue that 73-year-old theory is being tested right now for the very first time. And Adam, you've been carrying around Keynes's 1,000 page biography for weeks now getting ready for this story.
凯恩斯发表他的宏大理论——支撑奥巴马总统财政刺激计划的理论——是在1936年。很多人会认为那个73岁的理论现在正处于有史以来的第一次真正考验之中。亚当，为了这个故事，你已经随身携带凯恩斯的1000页传记好几周了。
Yeah, it's the abridged version, I should tell you. Yeah, it's huge. It's by this guy Lord Robert Skidelsky and it is such a great read because Keynes is totally fascinating. Every few pages I'm flipping between thinking he's an amazing, charming, genius and then that he's a narrow-minded jerk.
是的，我得告诉你，那是删节版。是的，它太厚了。它是罗伯特·斯基德尔斯基勋爵写的，读起来非常棒，因为凯恩斯绝对迷人。每读几页，我就会在认为他是一位令人惊叹、迷人、天才，然后认为他是一个狭隘混蛋之间来回切换。
I keep thinking that there are at least two movies you could make about Keynes. In one, you'd see Keynes as the statesman advising presidents and prime ministers and furiously writing up these papers that change the direction of modern intellectual thought.
我一直在想，关于凯恩斯至少可以拍两部电影。在第一部里，你会看到凯恩斯作为建议总统和总理的政治家，疯狂地撰写着改变现代知识思想方向的论文。
I can see the montage right now.
我现在就能看到那个蒙太奇镜头。
The paper writing montage.
论文撰写蒙太奇。
Yeah, the paper writing montage.
是的，论文撰写蒙太奇。
It's exciting. And then you'd zoom in on him coming up with the plan that some say save the free world from communist takeover after World War II. So that's one movie you could make. Another movie would pretty much be a gay porno.
很令人兴奋。然后你会聚焦于他提出了某些人所说的在二战后拯救自由世界免于共产主义接管的计划。所以这是一部你可以拍的电影。另一部电影差不多就是一部同性恋色情片。
Well, why don't you tell us more about that one then.
好吧，那你为什么不跟我们多说说那一部呢。
He ran with the Bloomsbury Group, you know, like Virginia Woolf and all those painters and poets. They were into free love and raunchy language and they used to complain in letters to each other that Keynes was just way too dirty for them.
他是布鲁姆斯伯里派的一员，你知道，像弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫和所有那些画家和诗人。他们热衷于自由恋爱和粗俗语言，他们过去在写给彼此的信中抱怨凯恩斯对他们来说太肮脏了。
So he was out there. In the early 1900s, he was an openly gay figure. He would take his boyfriends to fancy dinner parties. People referred to them as married. And then suddenly in 1925, after sleeping with a lot of his students at Cambridge and many other men in the Bloomsbury orbit, he married a woman and was by all accounts quite happy with her and faithful. You get this sense of a guy who did and said whatever he wanted.
所以他是很开放的。在20世纪初，他是一位公开的同性恋人物。他会带他的男朋友去参加豪华晚宴。人们称他们为已婚。然后突然在1925年，在与他在剑桥的许多学生以及布鲁姆斯伯里圈子里的许多男性发生关系后，他娶了一位女性，据各方说，他与她在一起非常快乐且忠诚。你会感觉到一个随心所欲、言行一致的家伙。
And that's just as true in his economics as in his private life. He loved hurling himself on the public stage with all these shocking, outrageous opinions. And the opinions were all over the place. Sometimes he's almost a socialist, then he's fanatically defending free markets.
而在他的经济学中，这和他私生活中一样真实。他喜欢带着所有这些令人震惊、骇人听闻的观点闯入公众舞台。而且这些观点各不相同。有时他几乎是个社会主义者，有时又狂热地捍卫自由市场。
Reading Keynes is kind of like reading the Bible. You could probably find a passage written sometime that justifies just about any position. But there is this common thread in what he wrote.
阅读凯恩斯就像阅读《圣经》。你可能随处都能找到某段文字能为几乎任何立场辩护。但他在他所写的东西中确实有一种共同的线索。
Sort of an elitist common thread.
某种精英主义的共同线索。
Yes, he generally felt that almost any problem could be solved by getting together a bunch of young men who had gone to Cambridge and asking them to run things. Every once in awhile, he might be OK with an Oxford man, but really Cambridge was best.
是的，他通常认为几乎任何问题都可以通过召集一群从剑桥出来的年轻人并让他们运行事情来解决。偶尔，他可能觉得牛津人也没问题，但事实上剑桥最好。
He even wanted Cambridge men to run America. He didn't think anyone in the US was smart enough. He also, by the way, didn't like Jews, the French, the working class.
他甚至想让剑桥人来管理美国。他认为美国没有任何人足够聪明。顺便说一句，他也不喜欢犹太人、法国人、工人阶级。
Yeah, and he had the sense that these Cambridge-led government boards should sort of run everything from individual companies to determining how many babies should be born and, he wrote cryptically, of what quality. He was, after all, on the board of directors of the British Eugenics Society.
是啊，他有种感觉，这些由剑桥领导的政府委员会应该像运行一切一样，从个人公司到决定应该生多少婴儿，并且，他隐晦地写道，是什么质量。毕竟，他是英国优生学会的董事会成员。
So here we are in modern day America, millions of working men and women in peril, and this is the guy we're turning to? A bigoted Americaphobe who hates working men and women?
所以我们现在处在现代美国，数以百万计的劳动男女处于危险之中，这就是我们转向的人？一个仇视工薪男女的狂妄的美国恐惧症患者？
Well, yes, and it's all because of this book he wrote in the 1930s. His prescription for how to get out of the global depression. It was his masterpiece, published in 1936, The General Theory of Employment, Interest and Money.
好吧，是的，这全是因为他在1930年代写的那本书。他关于如何走出全球萧条的处方。这是他的杰作，发表于1936年，《就业、利息和货币通论》。
I've read The General Theory about five times, I would guess. I think the first time I read it I was maybe 18.
我猜我已经读了《通论》大约五次了。我想我第一次读它时可能才18岁。
Tyler Cowen is an economist at George Mason University and he's been very publicly reading Keynes's masterwork again, this time writing notes and conducting a discussion on his blog, Marginal Revolution. He says it's no easier the sixth time around. Here is a sample sentence.
泰勒·考恩是乔治梅森大学的一位经济学家，他一直在非常公开地重读凯恩斯的杰作，这次是在写笔记，并在他的博客“边际革命”上进行讨论。他说第六次读也不见得容易。这里有一个样例句子。
"But it is a grave objection to this definition for such a purpose that the community's output of goods and services is a non-homogeneous complex which cannot be measured, strictly speaking, except in certain special cases as, for example, when all the items of one output are included in the same proportions in another output." And that's without looking. That was a purely random passage.
“但是对于这种目的来说，将这种定义作为一个严重反对意见，因为社区的商品和服务产出是一个非同质性的复杂体，严格来说是无法测量的，除非在某些特殊情况下，例如，当一种产出的所有项目以相同的比例包含在另一种产出中时。”而且不用看。那是一个纯粹随机的段落。
And that was like page what?
那大概是第几页？
That was page 38.
那是第38页。
Yeah, so it's hard to imagine too many people getting to page 39.
是啊，所以很难想象有太多人能读到第39页。
If you do make it through The General Theory, you learn that Keynes was correcting what he saw as a fundamental error in the economics that had come before. Under classical economics, if there's a downturn, the economy will sort itself out. If people aren't buying enough, prices will drop to where people start spending.
如果你读完了《通论》，你会了解到凯恩斯正在纠正他在之前的经济学中所认为的一个基本错误。在古典经济学下，如果有经济下行，经济会自我调节。如果人们购买不足，价格会下降到人们开始支出的程度。
Keynes's radical insight was to look out the window in the 1930s and see that sometimes things don't right themselves.
凯恩斯激进的洞察力是在1930年代向窗外看去，看到有时候事情并不会自我纠正。
And the economy goes into a downward spiral. Everything just gets worse and worse. And it looked, in the 1930s, as if that's what was happening. And to some extent, it was.
经济进入了螺旋式下降。一切都变得越来越糟。在1930年代，看起来好像就是那样。在某种程度上，确实如此。
A failure of effective demand, he called it.
他称之为有效需求不足。
This is another economist, Alan Blinder at Princeton, who was an economic adviser to President Clinton. A failure of effective demand, he says, is basically that people aren't spending enough money. Maybe they don't have any or they got laid off or they're afraid they're going to get laid off.
这是另一位经济学家，普林斯顿大学的艾伦·布林德，他曾是克林顿总统的经济顾问。有效需求不足，他说，基本上就是人们没有支出足够的钱。也许他们没钱，或者他们被解雇了，或者他们害怕会被解雇。
And if people aren't spending enough money, there's no way for the economy to automatically adjust. And in the 1930s, nobody else had figured out how to get people spending again.
如果人们没有支出足够的钱，经济就没有办法自动调节。在1930年代，没人能弄清楚如何让人们重新支出。
The Keynesian prescription is if all else fails, the government can spend the money. So normally we don't say in a free market economy, well, the government. We say, well, people and businesses should do it, but Keynes's idea, which was revolutionary at the time, is if the private sector won't do it, then the public sector can do it as a fill-in, a stop gap.
凯恩斯的处方是，如果一切都失败了，政府可以支出这笔钱。所以通常我们在自由市场经济中不说，好吧，政府。我们说，好吧，人和企业应该这样做，但凯恩斯的观点，在当时是革命性的，如果私营部门不做，那么公共部门可以作为填补者、权宜之计来做。
Blinder, like lots of Keynesians says that's basically what happened. Government spending got us out of the depression, but not in the way we learned in school. You know, I learned that FDR, inspired by Keynes, spent his way out of the depression.
布林德，像许多凯恩斯主义者一样，说这基本上就是所发生的事情。政府支出让我们走出了萧条，但不是我们在学校里学到的方式。你知道，我学到的是罗斯福受到凯恩斯的启发，通过支出走出了萧条。
FDR did expand the government spending. He started the WPA and the Tennessee Valley Authority and a whole alphabet soup of other programs, but he never spent as much money as Keynes said he should have. And he did all sorts of things that Keynes opposed, like raising taxes and trying to balance the budget, which Keynes said would just cancel out any positive effect from the spending.
罗斯福确实扩大了政府支出。他启动了工程进度署（WPA）和田纳西河谷管理局（TVA）以及一大堆其他的项目，但他从没像凯恩斯说的那样支出那么多钱。而且他做了各种各样凯恩斯反对的事情，比如提高税收和试图平衡预算，凯恩斯说那只会抵消支出的任何积极效果。
FDR sort of drove Keynes crazy, actually, and prompted at least one scolding letter. But then geopolitical events took over and forced FDR to spend as much money as Keynes wanted.
罗斯福实际上让凯恩斯发疯，并促使至少一封训斥信。但随后地缘政治事件接管了一切，并迫使罗斯福支出凯恩斯想要的那么多钱。
The huge dose of massive Keynesian stimulus came in the buildup to World War II. We started spending titanic amounts of money.
大规模凯恩斯主义刺激的巨剂量来自于二战前的积累。我们开始支出极其庞大的金额。
And was the way we ended the depression Keynesian? Was it--
那我们结束萧条的方式是凯恩斯主义的吗？那是……
Yeah, it was Keynesian, but it was not for that reason. I mean, it was to fight Hitler and to fight Tojo, but it was Keynesian.
是啊，那是凯恩斯主义的，但并不是出于那个原因。我的意思是，那是为了对抗希特勒和对抗东条英机，但那是凯恩斯主义的。
Keynes had a heart attack and died in early 1946, which left economists to basically fight over his ideas right through today. One of the first fights, did Keynes get us out of the depression? On one side, people like Alan Blinder, who still believes that a Keynesian dose of massive military spending did the job. On the other side, folks like Tyler Cowen.
凯恩斯在1946年初心脏病发作去世了，这让经济学家们基本上为了他的思想一直争吵到现在。第一场争论：是凯恩斯让我们走出了萧条吗？在一边，像艾伦·布林德这样的人，他仍然相信凯恩斯主义大剂量的巨额军事支出完成了这项工作。在另一边，像泰勒·考恩这样的人。
I don't agree with that at all. World War II was a time of economic misery. There was low consumption. There was rationing. Times were tough. It was a continuation of the Great Depression. The numbers for GDP were high because we were making tanks, but it didn't make people better off.
我根本不同意那一点。二战是一个经济痛苦的时期。消费很低。有配给制。日子很艰难。那是大萧条的延续。GDP的数字很高，因为我们在制造坦克，但这并没有让人们过得更好。
And unemployment was low because people were fighting a war.
失业率很低，因为人们在打仗。
But they were being killed. It was terrible. So the numbers are, in a way, phony, even though they look good. So in that sense, the war made the depression worse.
但他们被杀死了。那太可怕了。所以数字在某种程度上是虚假的，即使它们看起来不错。所以从那种意义上说，战争让萧条变得更糟了。
In terms of standard of living.
就生活水平而言。
In terms of real standard of living.
就实际生活水平而言。
Back in the 1940s, nobody was listening to that argument. For about 30 years after World War II, Keynesianism was mainstream economic theory, but during that time Keynes's theory morphed into something that Keynes himself wouldn't have recognized.
在1940年代，没有人听那个论点。二战后大约30年，凯恩斯主义是主流经济理论，但在那段时间里，凯恩斯的理论演变成了一种凯恩斯本人都不会认出来的东西。
Keynes's mantra was always uncertainty, what he once called the dark forces of time and ignorance which envelop our future. But his disciples came to believe that his theories could be used in a much more precise way to control the economy than Keynes ever believed.
凯恩斯的口头禅永远是不确定性，他曾经称之为笼罩我们未来的时间和无知的黑暗力量。但他的信徒开始相信他的理论可以以一种比凯恩斯本人认为的更精确的方式来控制经济。
So Keynes's disciples thought if the economy needs a little boost, you cut just enough taxes and increase just enough spending. If the economy is heating up, you do the opposite. You raise taxes by a couple of percentage points and cut government spending.
所以凯恩斯的信徒认为如果经济需要一点推动力，你就减一点税，增加一点支出。如果经济正在升温，你就做相反的事情。你提高几个百分点的税收，并削减政府支出。
Alan Blinder, the Keynesian economist at Princeton, says that there was a triumphant sense among Keynesians, that by carefully tweaking taxes and spending this way, they could overcome booms and busts. They could permanently eliminate recessions.
普林斯顿的凯恩斯主义经济学家艾伦·布林德说，凯恩斯主义者中有一种胜利感，通过这种方式小心地微调税收和支出，他们可以克服繁荣和萧条。他们可以永久消除衰退。
There was a view that developed in the 1960s-- and developed excessively, one must admit in retrospect-- that we could steer the national economy pretty well. Not perfectly, but pretty well. If you pick up Walter Heller's book that was written in the 1960s-- Walter Heller was the head of the Council of Economic Advisers for Kennedy. The amount of optimism exuded there seems almost laughable. This was a watch we were repairing.
在1960年代有一种观点发展起来——回顾过去必须承认是过度发展的——我们可以很好地操纵国民经济。不是完美，但相当好。如果你拿起沃尔特·海勒在1960年代写的那本书——沃尔特·海勒是肯尼迪经济顾问委员会的主席。其中散发的乐观情绪看起来简直是荒谬的。这是一个我们正在修理的手表。
One way the economy is not like a watch, when you repair a watch, politicians aren't involved. Politicians took the Keynesian message that government spending can be good and they kind of went nuts. They paid for the war on poverty, the Vietnam war, they sent a man to the moon, all the time running up the federal deficit, convinced that Keynes gave them a free pass.
经济不像手表的一种方式是，当你修理手表时，政客不参与。政客们接受了凯恩斯主义的信息，即政府支出可以是好的，他们有点发疯了。他们为反贫困战争、越南战争买单，他们把人送上月球，一直增加联邦赤字，坚信凯恩斯给了他们一张免费通行证。
For Keynesians this is always a problem. Prescribing Keynesianism to some politicians is like prescribing crack to a coke addict. They like it a little too much. And in the 1970s, the patient hit rock bottom.
对于凯恩斯主义者来说，这永远是个问题。向一些政客开凯恩斯主义药方就像向可卡因瘾君子开快克处方一样。他们太喜欢它了。在1970年代，病人跌入谷底。
We had high unemployment and the Keynesian solution stopped working. We spent and spent and unemployment got worse and we got inflation, something Keynesians had no answer for. After that, it was the Keynesians' turn to walk in the wilderness.
我们经历了高失业率，而凯恩斯主义的解决方案停止工作了。我们支出了再支出，而失业率变得更糟，我们经历了通胀，这是凯恩斯主义者没有答案的东西。在那之后，轮到凯恩斯主义者在荒野中行走。
When I took macroeconomics in the 1980s and early 1990s, the textbooks explained the basic Keynesian system but then spent a few chapters showing why the Keynesian system did not work.
当我在1980年代和1990年代初学习宏观经济学时，教科书解释了基础凯恩斯主义系统，但随后花了几个章节来展示为什么凯恩斯主义系统不工作。
This is economist Chris Edwards with the avowedly anti-Keynesian Cato Institute, a think tank founded in 1977 near Keynesianism's lowest point.
这是经济学家克里斯·爱德华兹，来自公认的反凯恩斯主义的卡托研究所，一个成立于1977年，接近凯恩斯主义最低点的智库。
I thought the debate was settled in the 80s and I thought we all agreed that Keynesianism doesn't work. But now with the new stimulus package before Congress all these Keynesians have come out of the woodwork.
我以为辩论在80年代就解决了，我以为我们都同意凯恩斯主义不起作用。但现在随着国会面前的新刺激方案，所有这些凯恩斯主义者都从木制品中出来了。
Did you know there were Keynesians around?
你知道周围有凯恩斯主义者吗？
Sure, but I thought the sort of kindergarten Keynesianism, as I call it-- the simple idea that the government could spend more money to grow the economy. I thought that really sort of simple Keynesian idea had died in the 1970s, but I was wrong.
当然，但我认为那种幼儿园凯恩斯主义，正如我所称的那样——政府可以支出更多钱来增长经济的简单想法。我以为那种简单的凯恩斯想法已经在70年代死掉了，但我错了。
Edwards is part of the school of thought that replaced Keynsianism. There are a bunch different groups in this school, the monitorists, the Chicago school, supply side economics.
爱德华兹是取代凯恩斯主义的思维流派的一部分。这个流派中有许多不同的团体，货币主义者、芝加哥学派、供应侧经济学。
And they use a different set of tools to steer the economy than the Keynesians. The Keynesians, remember, like to use taxes and government deficits. These anti-Keynesians said, never use those tools. All you have to do is have the central bank, the Fed, carefully control interest rates.
他们使用一套与凯恩斯主义者不同的工具来操纵经济。记住，凯恩斯主义者喜欢使用税收和政府赤字。这些反凯恩斯主义者说，永远不要使用那些工具。你所要做的就是让中央银行，美联储，小心地控制利率。
If the economy overheats, raise rates. If it starts to sputter, lower them. This is why you've heard so many newscasts in the last two decades about Alan Greenspan or Ben Bernanke raising or lowering interest rates.
如果经济过热，提高利率。如果它开始喘息，降低利率。这就是为什么你在过去二十年的新闻广播中听到这么多关于艾伦·格林斯潘或本·伯南克提高或降低利率的消息。
The Central Bank raised its federal funds rate by half a point.
中央银行将联邦基金利率提高了半个百分点。
The Federal Reserve Board's interest rate setting arm announced a quarter of a percent cut in a key overnight bank lending rate today.
联邦储备委员会的利率设定机构今天宣布将关键隔夜银行贷款利率下调四分之一个百分点。
The Federal Reserve raised the short-term interest rate today by a quarter percentage point to 4.75%.
联邦储备银行今天将短期利率提高了四分之一个百分点至4.75%。
The Keynesians and anti-Keynesians fought some bitter battles through the 1980s, but by the Clinton administration, most economists agreed on the basics. Some of Keynes's ideas are useful, but we're in a post-Keynesian world. The interest rate is the tool we use. This view held pretty much until exactly one month ago, December 16th, 2008, to be precise.
凯恩斯主义者和反凯恩斯主义者在1980年代打了几场激烈的仗，但到了克林顿政府时期，大多数经济学家对基础知识达成了共识。凯恩斯的一些思想是有用的，但我们处在一个后凯恩斯世界。利率是我们使用的工具。这种观点一直保持到整整一个月前，准确地说是2008年12月16日。
There was a surprise move at the Federal Reserve today. The Fed was expected to cut interest rates by a half point. Instead, the Fed cut the key lending rate by as much as a full point to zero. That's the lowest federal funds rate on record.
今天美联储有一个令人惊讶的举动。美联储预计会降低半个百分点的利率。相反，美联储将关键贷款利率下调了整整一个百分点至零。这是记录在案的最低联邦基金利率。
That's the day the Fed tried to stabilize the economy by lowering interest rates all the way down to 0%. It can't go lower. But the economy kept getting worse. Their main tool seemed to have stopped working.
那是美联储通过将利率降至0%来试图稳定经济的那一天。它不能再低了。但经济持续恶化。他们的主要工具似乎已经停止工作了。
So economists and policy makers started looking around for some other way to fix things and they found that there's one guy in particular who'd given a lot of thought about how to get out of a situation like this.
所以经济学家和政策制定者开始寻找其他方法来修复事情，他们发现有一个人特别考虑过如何摆脱像这样的情况。
OK, so here's the way Keynes would have done it. So you measure here output.
好的，这就是凯恩斯会做的方式。所以你在这里测量产出。
We're in Alan Blinder's office at Princeton, which conveniently has a blackboard. And he's up there applying Keynes's formula-- it's pretty straightforward-- for how to get out of a mess like the one we're in.
我们在普林斯顿艾伦·布林德的办公室，那里有一个很方便的黑板。他正在那里应用凯恩斯的公式——它非常直截了当——来摆脱我们所处的混乱。
You start with some estimates. First, you guess what the economy would be producing if all the people and factories and businesses were working at full capacity. Blinders guess, that's around $15 trillion. And then you look at what the economy is actually producing. Let's put that at $14 trillion.
你从一些估计开始。首先，你猜测如果所有的人、工厂和企业都满负荷运转，经济会产生什么。布林德猜测，那是大约15万亿美元。然后你看看经济实际在产生什么。让我们把它定在14万亿美元。
So do you know those numbers on--
所以你知道那些数字在……
You don't know any of these numbers. You estimate all of them.
你不知道任何这些数字。你估计它们中的每一个。
So the economy should be producing $15 trillion, but it's only producing $14 trillion. There's $1  trillion shortfall. So the theory says that if the government spends money, or gives us money to spend through tax cuts, that will increase everybody's spending and get the economy back to where it should be.
所以经济应该产生15万亿美元，但它只产生14万亿美元。有1万亿美元的缺口。所以理论说，如果政府支出钱，或者通过减税给我们钱来支出，那将增加每个人的支出，并使经济回到它应该在的地方。
The government doesn't have to spend the whole $1 trillion shortfall, though, because of something called the Keynesian multiplier. Every dollar the government spends produces more than a dollar in spending throughout the economy. If they pay you to build a bridge, you spend your paycheck on rent and food and so on, and then those people have money to spend on other stuff. So, according to Keynes, there's a clear answer to how much Mr. Obama's administration should spend.
政府不必支出整个1万亿美元的缺口，虽然如此，因为有一个叫做凯恩斯乘数的东西。政府支出的每一美元在整个经济中产生的支出超过一美元。如果他们付钱给你盖一座桥，你把薪水花在租金和食物上等等，然后那些人就有钱花在其他东西上。所以，根据凯恩斯，奥巴马先生的政府应该支出多少有一个明确的答案。
To raise the GDP by $1 trillion. Suppose your multiplier was around one and a half, so that would lead you to conclude that you needed about $650 billion as a stimulus. Voila. That's the kind of number they're talking about right now. You see it in the newspapers every day, a number in that range.
将GDP提高1万亿美元。假设你的乘数大约是1.5左右，那么这会让你得出结论，你需要大约6500亿美元作为刺激。瞧。那就是他们现在每天在谈论的那种数字。你在报纸上每天都能看到它，在这个范围内的数字。
Have you done this more rigorously for yourself?
你自己更严格地做过这个吗？
I have not, but I hope they have.
我没有，但我希望他们有。
Right now, a lot of economists are supporting the idea of a stimulus package. There are people you'd expect, like Paul Krugman, a proud Keynesian at The New York Times, and there are some surprises like President Reagan's Chief Economic Adviser Martin Feldstein. When I talked to economists, I found a lot are in the middle, not convinced it'll work, but in the absence of anything else, they figure let's give it a try.
现在，许多经济学家正在支持刺激方案的想法。有你预期的人，比如《纽约时报》引以为豪的凯恩斯主义者保罗·克鲁格曼，还有一些惊喜，比如雷根总统的首席经济顾问马丁·费尔德斯坦。当我与经济学家交谈时，我发现很多人处于中间地带，不相信它会起作用，但在没有其他东西的情况下，他们想试试看。
But the frightening thing about a stimulus package is that no matter which economists you talk to-- the ones who want the Keynesian stimulus and the ones who think it's the worst idea ever-- are looking at exactly the same data. They're just coming to utterly opposite conclusions about it. This, even economists like Alan Blinder will tell you, is the problem with economics.
但刺激方案可怕的事情是，无论你和哪位经济学家交谈——想要凯恩斯主义刺激的人，还是认为这是有史以来最糟糕想法的人——都在看完全相同的数据。他们只是对它得出了完全相反的结论。这，即使像艾伦·布林德这样的经济学家也会告诉你，是经济学的问题。
The biggest problem with learning things in economics is the inability to do controlled experiments. So we don't have-- unlike what is the case in many but not all sciences-- the definitive experiment. Right? This experiment they did in the 1920s proved that Einstein was right about the perturbation of mercury. It proved it. We can never do that in economics.
学习经济学最大的问题是无法做控制实验。所以我们没有——不像在许多但不是所有科学中的情况——决定性的实验。对吧？他们在1920年代做的这个实验证明了爱因斯坦关于水星摄动的理论是正确的。它证明了。我们在经济学中永远做不到这一点。
The best you can have is a really good theory.
你最好的拥有是一个非常好的理论。
The best you can have is a real good theory. It's not going to work perfectly in a textbook manner all the time.
你最好的拥有是一个真实的良好理论。它不会一直以教科书的方式完美地工作。
For Tyler Cowen, though, this is about as good as it gets for testing Keynes's theory. Remember, he like a lot of anti-Keynesians, doesn't think Keynes got us out of the depression. He doesn't support Barack Obama's stimulus plan. He thinks Keynes was probably wrong. But if we do the stimulus and the economy quickly recovers--
然而，对于泰勒·考恩来说，这已经是对测试凯恩斯理论最好的情况了。记住，像许多反凯恩斯主义者一样，他不认为凯恩斯让我们走出了萧条。他不支持巴拉克·奥巴马的刺激计划。他认为凯恩斯可能是错的。但如果我们进行刺激而经济迅速复苏——
That would prove that Blinder is right and I am wrong.
那将证明布林德是对的，而我是错的。
Definitively?
决定性地？
Well, no test is definitive, but it would be strong evidence. If we spend $700 billion and the economy recovers within a year or a year and a half, I would take that as serious evidence that my view is wrong. I don't think it will happen, but I would take it seriously.
好吧，没有测试是决定性的，但那将是强有力的证据。如果我们支出7000亿美元，而经济在一年或一年半内复苏，我会将其视为我的观点错误的严重证据。我不认为那会发生，但我会认真对待它。
So, this just happens to be-- just the elements that have come together right now have just accidentally created the perfect conditions for this test.
所以，这正好是——正好现在聚在一起的元素偶然创造了测试的完美条件。
Near perfect. I view this, if we decide to, as the first test of Keynesian fiscal policy as a formula for getting out of a depression. The very first test. It's one reason why I don't want to do it, because in my opinion, the idea's untested. So to spend, say, $1 trillion on an untested idea, in my view, is a mistake.
接近完美。如果我们决定这样做，我将此视为凯恩斯主义财政政策作为摆脱萧条公式的第一次测试。第一次测试。这是我不想做它的一个原因，因为在我看来，这个想法未经过测试。所以支出，比如说，1万亿美元在一个未经测试的想法上，在我看来，是一个错误。
There are lots of economists who think a Keynesian stimulus would be a mistake for all sorts of reasons. Some say you don't need a stimulus to fix the recession because a recession isn't a disease that needs a cure. It is the cure. A recession brings down prices from a falsely inflated high. A recession is what makes houses affordable again.
有许多经济学家认为凯恩斯主义刺激会是各种原因下的一个错误。有些人说你不需要刺激来修复衰退，因为衰退不是一种需要治愈的疾病。它就是治愈方法。衰退会使价格从虚高水平降下来。衰退是使房屋再次变得负担得起的原因。
Others say a stimulus package might end the recession but then we'll have worse problems later on: vicious inflation, a bigger, less efficient government, and $1 trillion more in debt to pay off. The Obama administration is betting that none of this will happen. They're trusting a different theory. They're trusting Keynes.
其他人说刺激方案可能会结束衰退，但随后我们以后会有更糟糕的问题：恶性通胀、一个更大、效率更低的政府，以及多出1万亿美元的债务需要偿还。奥巴马政府押注这一切都不会发生。他们相信一个不同的理论。他们相信凯恩斯。
Alex Blumberg and Adam Davidson. You can hear them do economics coverage in normal human language several times a week at the Planet Money podcast. To find that, google Planet Money.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格和亚当·戴维森。你可以在Planet Money播客上每周多次听到他们用正常人类语言进行经济报道。要找到那个，谷歌Planet Money。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and me with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Andrew Dixon. Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好的，我们的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作帮助来自安德鲁·迪克森。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight of our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who does not want to be dragged into the credits of our show. He doesn't want to. He doesn't like it, though he says he might be persuaded. Yes, he might be persuaded one last time.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共电台分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他不想被拖入我们节目的职员表。他不想。他不喜欢它，尽管他说他可能会被说服。是的，他可能会在最后一次被说服。
I told you, I'm out of the game. What'd you say? Actually it sounds like it might be kind of fun.
我告诉过你，我金盆洗手了。你说什么？其实听起来可能挺好玩的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week for more stories of This American Life. P R I, Public Radio International.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来观看更多《美国生活》的故事。P R I，国际公共电台。